simon you're up buddy uh hi rich yeah so
um i just yeah on the question of
cheating um
i know what you meant when guys uh today
monogamously
especially in the 20s um before marriage
that is um but
my question just extends to uh married
people
because of okay from what rollo said in
uh rational male is that women want
someone capable of cheating
but not too cheap essentially but
then you've also got um like people like
kevin samuel saying
uh married men don't i mean high valued
men don't cheat their exercise options
so i mean it's kind of hard to form like
a moral standpoint to argue to agree
with
like men or women who do cheat uh you
know i
like even though i just come across the
red pill ideology i still find it
morally hard to maybe accept okay
someone
who does cheat once they get married of
course i mean okay well
have you have you read any evolutionary
psychology
no i haven't you'll understand why men
and women cheat and you'll also
understand why
men and women cheat for different
reasons like when women cheat they're
they're basically done there's only
there's only one instance where
women cheat and they stay with the guy
and it's if it's beta bucks like solid
beta bucks
right like she'll use him to pay for
the house the mortgage the cottages the
vacation the children
all that stuff while she'll go to pound
town with kevin from sales
okay that's that's an example of
cheating where they'll stay with the guy
but usually when women cheat in a
long-term relationship
it's because she's done and and she's
and she's monkey branching
with that guy right like women like
i think the numbers something like more
than 50 percent of women have a backup
plan
women's surveyed in a long-term
relationship or a
marriage admit 50 of them admit to
having a back-up plan so
the other 50 are either not willing to
admit that they have a backup plan or
they don't have a backup plan
but on a balance of probabilities women
have backup plans lined up
meaning that if they're going to cheat
it's with a guy that they're basically
monkey branching over to
when men cheat is just because they want
strange they just want some variety
that's it
like we're men make millions of sperm
every month we're here to scatter our
seed there's no question about that
women make one egg
per month that's it
so would that explain that okay married
women
even though they don't like the idea of
that man cheating
even if he does cheat they still
wouldn't leave him because
i've i've i've spoken to
probably hundreds of men now um
that have had multiple affairs
some cases multiple mistresses in some
cases a notch
like racked up a notch count well over
100 during their marriage
and their wife just looked the other way
watch um
watch the documentary on netflix um on
the crown
it's about the uh you know it's you know
more else about the royal family and you
start to catch win that prince philip
was
pretty much uh a chad banging whoever he
wanted whatever he wanted and the queen
looked the other way
the most powerful woman in the world
hmm yep right
so when men and women do it okay like
men and women cheat
women cheat just as much as guys do but
they do it for different reasons
today women do it for evolutionary
reasons but they also do it
a lot more now too because they're told
to behave like men
toxic feminism just makes feminine women
into terrible men that's all that it
does
but from a moral standpoint would you
say
that once you get into it i mean once
you obviously get into a marriage
whether morally for both genders it
would be
wrong facts don't care about feelings
dude like
whenever guys go on about the moral
standpoint of this that or the other
thing
the fact of the matter is is that human
beings are not monogamous
we're highly promiscuous primates that's
what we are
right so there's so do it from the
context of
let's say a child and let's say the
child's parents so one of the parents
this enter into something like that
whether it affects them
their viewpoint of that parent not so
much of
the people of a parent but from the
viewpoint of a child that's the way i'm
looking at
yeah well i don't i don't know what age
child you're talking about but
but children aren't equipped to deal
with
uh romantic relationships until they've
become adults
right so you shouldn't be exposing
children to any of this stuff
okay let them be kids yeah oh also
uh yeah i'll be great to see you on the
fresh and fit podcast
yeah i i really enjoy watching them i
think you'll be good in dealing with the
ladies there
listen don't don't sit on the sidelines
watching the show go on
all the time and and get into the red
meat there's a lot of [ __ ] shows out
there that are all about the red meat
let's get eyeballs on us because you
know we can expose these garden tools
for what they are and everybody just
kind of sits there and throws money at
it and they're in the chat and they're
like oh
rah-rah-rah get on the ice and try to
score a goal yourself man you know chase
excellence you know do something i don't
like it when i hear guys
you know go on about how much time they
spend sitting on the sidelines
watching other people throw red meat
around
yeah okay i'm not saying that i'm not
going to go on the fresh and fit podcast
it ain't happening anytime soon though
yeah
all right bro i'll see you later peace
you